hi if you support the rule of law
sometimes it's the small victories you
have to celebrate that's what we got
this week in a czar vs. alina health
services decided by the Supreme Court in
that case we found that often Congress
is supposed to make the laws of the
country that's what our Constitution
says but in reality almost all of our
laws are actually made by bureaucrats
while that's a violation of our
constitutional separation of powers we
do have a system to try to limit what
agencies do on their own and that limit
is to force them to give notice to the
public ahead of time of what they are
going to regulate and allow comment by
the public of what they believe should
be done about a particular rule now the
government tried to violate this even
the small limit in the past case that
was discussed this week what the
government tried to do was to skirt this
even small limit on the bureaucracies
power the Medicare system gives
reimbursements to low income for
low-income patients when they go to
hospitals and the government tried to
change the rules on how they give these
reimbursements to the hospital systems
now what the government tried to argue
here and then the court rejected
seven-to-one was that they didn't have
to follow these rules and what the court
had said in that 71 ruling isn't of
course enough to restore constitutional
government it's not a full restoration
of the separation of powers but it is a
small victory for the rule of law in the
following ways it does require that a
law exists before it can be enforced it
does require that a law be followed as
written by Congress it does require that
the public know about the law before
they can be punished or have their lives
changed regarding it and finally it
gives a tiny bit of power and leeway to
the public to give some consent of the
governed to the rule making our
bureaucrats do is that enough to restore
a constitutional government
is it enough to restore the rule of law
no but it's a small step in the right
direction